Thanos comes into though his young self
coming into the present right and when I
was painting it on his hand is the skull
of
[Music]
you know the the fortunate thing about
working the fortunate and unfortunate
thing about work at Marvel uh this
visual development team is you know we
start the process of developing it like
a year before you know even two years
sometimes before the actual uh choosing
who the actors are or any of that stuff
you know if I could have you like
commission a piece of art for me
um I would I would love to just sit in
on the Shawarma scene
just like you know just sitting at the
side table like just looking at
everybody just chowing down I
I would get it blown up to make it look
like a big you know like oil painting
and just have it look like the Last
Supper
that'll be awesome man yeah that idea is
really cool maybe maybe it could be for
even something
that's for later and then you have
shanxi there and you have everyone like
eating Shawarma together completely yeah
get yeah get all the but we're going
into phase four right is this is this
um you got phase four secrets for me
uh
no
okay yeah yeah we just talked about
secrecy yeah
we get the whole script so I get to read
through it and stuff but the only time
that I didn't get the full script was
for Infinity War
and end game especially I had a scene
I was doing where uh where Thanos comes
into the the you know his uh end game
his his young self coming into the
present right and when I was painting it
on his hand
is the skull of Captain America
that was in his head no I was like is
Captain America gonna die no he's gonna
die
and then when I saw the film I was like
oh they tricked me it's it's Iron Man's
gonna die and and I guess and I heard
they were giving false scripts to
certain people not giving you know all
their main who the characters are that's
dying just so no one really knows you
know and I didn't know they did that
with us too but but there's a
possibility I guess they were choosing
between the two big guys you know
that's insane I I honestly I think the
the health of the comic book Universe
really depends on the ability to
surprise the audience these days comic
book fans are smart They're Gonna Know
What To Expect if they get any clues as
to what the project is going to entail
so like
I think that's where
where the university you've been working
in Excel is the best is you actually
surprise the audience you know you don't
you don't announce certain cast members
until people watch it revealed on screen
yeah oh man that's true do you have okay
speaking of speaking of like next phase
I gotta ask do you have any any insights
any spoilers any anything you can tell
me about
guardians of galaxy
the new one and three big news something
something that's gonna like you know
make my jaw drop
[Laughter]
um I worked on Groot
which is kind of out now you could see
him in uh Disney plus but you've seen
the trailers
um him with like 12 arms yeah multiple
arms
and that was that was awesome like
getting to design that
um
I design I helped designs uh well my my
design was approved for uh
High evolutionary I don't even know if I
could say that did they say that in the
film in the trailer oh man I'm so scared
now
probably not what's nice is it is my
last um
it's nice that that was the last show I
worked on before
um leaving Marvel so it's like a full
circle
uh you know guys one to Gardens three
and you know
uh it would be fun to work with James
again in the future the comic book
Universe has never been
this healthy you know like we have we
have content for everybody for every age
range from yeah you know I think some of
the older comic book heads complaining
about how they had to wait in line for
the new release and like they had to you
know they had to yeah bullying at school
but like now like comic book or comic
books are so mainstream that it's it's
it's the cool thing and I love I love to
see that you know in in a medium in our
form is
kind of leading the way and being able
to
broadcast diversity in a way that like
other genres and mediums haven't been
able to do the artistic process like
I mean your your medium is is very
visual in my and my medium is is is very
emotional but I feel like the process to
manifest the characters almost the same
like you're considering a lot of the the
attributes prior to an actor ever even
touching the character you're wanting to
make sure that the the visual look is
conveying a story as well am I right
yeah I would say you're a bit you know
you're a visual too Visual and
emotionals uh it would I think it would
parallel both because you have to make
sure you show your expression in your
acting and to get that expression you
need to feel it first you know so I I
designed the same way I go with feeling
first and then when I when when I've got
that feeling then maybe I could look for
reference but most of the time if you've
worked for a long time you don't need to
look for reference you just it's off
your head and you just go even if it's
not accurate
um and sometimes you need help right you
listen to a good piece of music or talk
to friends right that are experiencing
this kind of stuff um but it is a very
emotional
um for me anyway for me it's emotional I
have a surprise for you actually
[Laughter]
there it is man that's that's why Marvel
hires you man that that word that's
seamless kidding aside I'm gonna show
you what it really is all right fans
here it is
there he is
can you see it
that is so sick and you just you just
painted this didn't you yeah yesterday
did you just this is you I mean I I
didn't paint your face because I was in
a hurry
but I was thinking of putting a Omni man
right there you know in the reflection
yeah yeah but then it was it was taking
too much from your face so but uh but
you know your head's like bleeding and I
I I see my like my my cheesy grin in
there
he's bleeding but the but the grin is
still there thank you
man dude thank you the suit design is
Fun the the lines are crazy I appreciate
you giving me that that Superhero Dorito
shape you know yeah
they just have to
they have to just put these shoulders I
think and you'll get that that V for
sure you know I I I you know the the
last few years of of superhero boot camp
over on Titans definitely definitely got
me those proportions and uh yeah like
I'm I'm I'm definitely ready to answer
the call Kirkman
[Laughter]
I was wondering it was their favorite
character you would like to play or um
oh in the in the DC Universe
um
super boy no super uh
uh man I mean
i i i i I'd really love to see
um
DC fans just happy and and I'd love for
DC to have to have some solid wins uh so
for the time being
um I I'm just gonna object objectively
take a step back I'm still subjectively
very much involved
um I love these characters uh there's
there's actually one character in
particular that when I moved to the
states
um I watch Teen Titans I love Teen
Titans
um but the other DC animated show that I
grew up with was Batman Beyond and I I
somewhere I have a photo of me dressed
in that like costume when I was like
maybe eight
um I just remember the the art style was
cool Terry wasn't like this huge guy
he'd like you know he didn't have all
the ability but it was it was the heart
it was the attempt at at saving people
and and Batman being kind of his mentor
there's a lot
about Batman Beyond that worked for me
as a kid I loved that show
um and I'd really love to see DC if they
are going in a new direction to
to kind of move away from the big three
but hey look if if we're talking if
we're talking you know dream projects
Beyond like it's yeah yeah
what do you think
what do you think DC needs to do from
from your experience in the comic book
world for the last
10 years
for DC I think
I think it's a good move getting James
Gunn to kind of Helm a lot of the stuff
uh
he is really good at I mean
Guardians of the Galaxy the first movie
I ever worked on at Marvel really
um is memorable to me and they were
unknown characters and that to me is his
strength like taking these characters
making them a family
and
if anything him making DC Universe more
of a family
would would benefit the DCU I I think I
know you you write stuff too you you you
you contribute so much in in the process
I'm very very grateful for the kind of
um broad reaching superhero uh knowledge
I have like I I'm not too familiar with
any one property in particular I've just
kind of dabbled in a little bit of all
of it
um so I tried to have the writing that I
contributed to reflect that I wanted to
tell Titans stories
um
that that
would be
multi-generate fans would like yeah
multi-generational because what Marv
Wolfman and George Perez did with the
new Teen Titans was phenomenal it really
established the the the the big bads the
the the the family Dynamics and then
what John's did with his Titans first
really kind of expanded on the the team
aspects like these characters suddenly
be felt younger and they felt yeah
um not more vulnerable but more
relatable relatable um yeah yeah
definitely yeah I think that's when they
got into it more because of that yeah
totally and then when the animated show
came up came around they took
all the existing material and just
it's I it's it's an animated Masterpiece
in my mind like every episode really
dives into the psychology of the
characters and gives the characters
character-driven motives and plot points
that serve the Arc of each one but also
servicing the family as a whole and
um whenever I pitched lines and just
kind of
you know it had little had little quips
on set I tried for them to be
reminiscent of the the characters from
the comic books and the Animated Series
um and I got to contribute to uh two
scripts uh this this season and
um a couple plot points throughout the
season as well and
I'm thrilled I I really I really can't
wait for people to see in part two
um beast boys
I would say it's it's it's his it's a
standalone episode it's um oh that's so
cool yeah we get to we get to really
live in his his mind and his heart for a
little while and
we Bridge all of the
seasonal
um plot points and and traumas that he's
gone through in one episode there's it
was a bit of a it was a bit of a big
task
um while introducing new characters and
while having surprises for the fans
um I think we
we really did something special and I
hope when the fans watch it they're like
this feels like the animated show you
know because a lot of his storytelling
is done visually you know like hey he
wears the expression he wears the joke
on his face and like he transforms into
an animal to tell a joke I was just
thinking of the gags you know because I
would do that a lot at in Marvel Studios
visual development team we don't just
design the characters and creatures and
stuff we do the key frames and we even
storyboard and we do like little
animatics of stuff you know like
in the end of end game we did a bunch of
gags on how uh to you know how do you
say
um like team-ups to get the uh The
Gauntlet away from
um
doing interesting pairs so like visually
they look good on camera but how do
their powers sync up and like how would
they be able to work with one another if
one is you know Valkyrie right like yeah
yeah
and like
yeah I that's something iconic
that whole sequence is so much fun
yeah it's it's fine I had one where I
had uh Ant-Man riding one of the
leviathans but that didn't go through
um so you you worked on you worked on
Quantum Mania when I watched it uh it it
was it was awesome I really enjoyed um
the epicness of it and it's still light
and and heartfelt and um the designs
the the world still looks amazing to me
yeah oh did you get to see um did you
get to see my latest design for Groot in
the Christmas special on Disney plus yes
dude I I loved it I loved it
that's based off my son still because
he's you know he's older now he's 15.
he's almost my height and that facial
structure kind of you know looks like
him a little bit
um but he's a gymnast so his arms are
actually
pretty buff
I'm glad James liked it you know um
because I was like saying inspiration is
my son and uh this tree called the
balita tree from the Philippines and
that is the cheese so like you have
roots coming down the side so I was
using those as a as a part of his
groot's body right so he's like
yeah so I it is it is a memory of his
cherished forever quite literally rooted
in the culture it's beautiful man rooted
in the culture yes
dude it's it's been it's been awesome to
see groot's Journey as a result of you
and your son's journey and that's
something that you kind of had told me
when we first met and I I think it's I I
think it's beautiful you know I whether
whether people want to believe it or not
I I know that Groot is Filipino and yeah
that that the Pinoy fried it's beautiful
it's beautiful okay nice Pride
Pinoy Fried Chicken I'm not just kidding
[Music]